hey guys how's it going I'm Justine and
today we are back in the kitchen and we
are going to be making a football cape
the Super Bowl is coming up and today
it's depending on while you're watching
this the Steelers are playing the
Patriots and I want to be supportive of
my team so I'm going to make a football
few escape some course of European have
another football team feel free to
replace the Steelers name and logo with
your own sports just out of curiosity
I'm wondering what your favorite
football team is leave me some comments
below and lowest points for Steelers
fans
ok let's get the items ready we got to
get them all prepared and ready to make
the cake try a chocolate cake change
plans we're gonna make a chocolate cake
I haven't made a chocolate cake in a
really long time so we're really
switching things up here I guess I could
probably make one cake I'm just not
really sure how I'm gonna do this it's
like how I make it look like football
like I'm not sure you like chocolate
cake are you actually gonna maybe yes
I'm actually probably capable with my
absolute favorite thing that my mom made
well yeah
hers is definitely for sure it was
better it doesn't agree on taters here
and my standards are super low half cup
in one 1/4 are these feel good February
2nd don't have my Apple watch on think
we're all right 1 2 3
looking good gonna be fill thankless
like dashes
I'm thinking it's finally time that I
should probably get a new one of these
because it's starting to fall apart cuz
lid doesn't sit on here at all like he
doesn't even stay on anymore
lifetime warranty
I think I've perfected how to make cakes
now in the blender you got to add your
liquid ingredients first slowly add in
the rest which it doesn't say on it all
it looks like a milkshake we understand
for this all in because I gotta hurry up
what's wrong
looks pretty good I'm fried quite
impressed and you go
alright well no put this into the oven
let it bake for 30 to 40 minutes and I
will see you guys back here very very
very very very shortly alright we're
back everything I think is working out
point well I've got the cake cooling in
the freezer because why would I not it's
still super warm Wow okay well bots are
flip it over a little bad at all
actually quite impressed now I'm going
to somehow turn this into a football
kind of like the question maybe not a
bad idea I was going to level it but
since it's a football I feel like it
kind of looks good rounded so we're not
even going to need this hey it's a
football why I Drive like that where the
elders would burn it can be really hard
it can be nice and tall I think if I had
cake before yeah well when you try this
cake you give it like wow okay that's
actually quite good he's going to love
it
it's really good roll it up
[Music]
shoot shoot this is going to be a very
tiny football so amazing I just kind of
like trying to like chisel away at it to
sort of make it look like a little more
football ish so it's not bad it's just
not good
I had how I am super I hope guys okay
not done yet so it doesn't look that
good but it isn't that bad but I think
we're going to be able to salvage it and
make it look good enough it's going to
look like a very nice football and be
ready for some Steelers peeler win
hopefully
oh well good I know all right
waiter than what I made I was quite
impressed with how the turnout is
running out Wow I don't know what you do
guys I've a problem because this is not
drawing this beautiful logo like with
even like a pen and a pencil is
difficult and some things are not
working out well I couple the blue a
little bit get a blue look uh I can't
even draw ah I can't even draw this
feeling will go like by hand
Oh what icing it was really difficult
very surprised can we eat it now no
tomorrow tomorrow but I'm so hungry
though that's a nice day thank you wait
a minute wait the spot no you let me
smell it
you can try it some of that with some
icing don't do it mmm that's why see I'm
so crazy I'm a purple haired bread it's
gone how come you guys are all in this
video but no one to be my date oh this
is good well you think map old oh my god
you need to get now we are you okay how
do I get by help like we never eaten
before we haven't I'm so hungry I think
they're up there oh my girl look more
icing on there no it's perfect
I wrote guys okay can I um maybe offer
you like napkin or like some insulin she
all right guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed this
video and as I said in the beginning if
you haven't already leave me a comment
below and let me know who your favorite
sports team is and if you do decide to
make yourself a sports cake book ball
cake whatever it is with you I mean
whatever sport it is if you like it can
be like hockey or baseball Chi send me
some pictures I'd love to see them
but this I think turned out pretty well
clearly the Steelers logo not that good
but I I really did try my best
also leave me some comments on what you
would like to see me make next
I'm running out of ideas all I do is
bake cakes because it's the only thing
that I could actually do correct and I'm
very very proud of the ID later
[Music]
all right we got them so some guy wanted
to return to to get a different color so
I swapped out the coral for